bonjour benjamin cauchy merci beaucoup
d'être on dirait que ce matin avec nous
sur rt france on va attendre votre
contradicteur qui ne saurait tarder non
alors la question qu'on entend partout
sur les médias en ce moment c'est
faut-il débattre avec eric zemmour c'est
la question qui a été posée à jean luc
mélenchon qu'en pensez vous est ce que
cette question est justifié pourquoi
débattre avec jean luc mélenchon
finalement
pourquoi ne pas débattre et finalement
les observateurs sont ravis de voir que
jean luc mélenchon finalement à changer
son fusil d'épaulé depuis plusieurs
semaines depuis plusieurs mois
d'ailleurs lorsque
eric zemmour était sur l'antenne de
seignosse régulièrement avec proposé à
plusieurs reprises de recevoir jean luc
mélenchon pour pouvoir évoquer
finalement des sujets de son et
notamment ce schisme intellectuelle
qu'il ya entre ces deux hommes de talent
qui sont deux tribuns qui sont de deux
hommes qui savent à la fois manier les
idées et les mots et qui ont des
convictions l'un et l'autre bien trempé
mais des visions de sociétés des visions
de de notre france dans 30 ans bien
différente moi je crois avoir à la fois
du piment intellectuelle et le mérite
politique de clarifier finalement des
positions parfois obscur chez jean luc
mélenchon et peut-être de clarifier
aussi quelques positions que l'on fait à
eric zemmour alors voilà on va on va
regarder ce qu'on a dit justement jean
luc mélenchon il a justifié sa présence
face aux polémistes regardées
je les ai connus brillant commentateurs
et puis je les ai vu s'effondrer il a
une idée de l'histoire de france qui est
sectaire il est d'extrême droite et
incarne tout ce que j'ai toujours
combattu alors jean-luc mélenchon en
fait un combat personnel est-ce qu'il a
raison selon vous
non là pour le coup je passe est une
erreur ne peut pas être un combat
personnel mais plutôt un combat d'idées
combat idéologique un combat
philosophique mails entre entre entre
deux visions de l'absence comme je vous
disais il ya quelques instants vous
allez jean luc mélenchon qui est ce qui
promeut le multi culturalisme qui prône
finalement une ouverture au monde
extrêmement sorte peut-être se sent
suffisamment de deux barrières de
contraintes je pense aux contrôles
notamment démographiques de flux
migratoires
de l'autre on a ri zemmour qui souhaite
lui en revanche m comme l'église au
milieu du village remettre au coeur du
projet potentiellement présidentielle ce
choc de fizi de civilisation qui
s'approche à grand pas entre cette
civilisation judéo-chrétienne qu'incarne
finalement cette histoire
multimillénaire de la france et un jean
luc mélenchon qui lui en revanche
estiment que la france de se diluer dans
une sorte de mondialisme et d'avoir les
des portes ouvertes en permanence et
reste extrêmement intéressant jean luc
mélenchon pg se préparer à ce débat du
côté d'el eric zemmour comment est ce
qu'ils se préparent à ce duel ce soir
alors un esprit j'ai envie de dire
combatif et puis on est allés chez
également jubilatoire c'est à dire que
la joute verbale le choc des idées la
confrontation des idées avec un tribun
aussi intéressant que peut être jean luc
mélenchon ne peut que stimuler un
intellectuel qui a toujours aimé le
débat la contradiction je vous défie de
me trouver une personne qui séduit
refusé de débattre avec avec eric
zemmour eric zemmour a toujours accepté
de débattre avec d'autres personnes donc
ils piquent travail il conçut qu'il
reçoit il écoute beaucoup on pourrait
estimer que eric zemmour a la science
infuse et que de toutes sortes de la
cuisse de jupiter non pas du tout il
écoute les français niels un prêt de la
réalité parce que finalement c'est ça
que les gens aiment chez eric zemmour
c'est qu'ils s'imprègnent de la réalité
et décrit la réalité que je lui hier
plutôt serein tout assuré qu'il est
plutôt ça alors benjamin cauchy on a on
à philippe juraver de la france
insoumise qui était qui est avec nous
par téléphone malheureusement bonjour
philippe jura avait merci beaucoup
d'être nous en direct sur rt france
on écoutait benjamin cauchy dit dire que
finalement c'était un débat qui allait
être de haut niveau intellectuel et que
c'était intéressant quel est votre avis
sur ce débat la france insoumise a
toujours refusé de débattre avec eric
zemmour il l'a même ils l'ont même
boycotté pourquoi accepter aujourd'hui
alors disons pour commencer jean luc
mélenchon le candidat d'un programme on
a d'un programme de l'a 36 lits et les
atomic nous sommes je suis impatient car
tout le monde entende eric zemmour sur
des questions pratiques notamment sur la
partie sociale écologique voilà une
chose sur laquelle ne s'explique pas et
on a des questions concrètes qui lui
seront posées et c'est sur ce terrain là
j'ai envie d'entendre et avec des mots
parce que pour l'instant on n'a pas
entendu sur les choses qui intéressent
le quotidien des dépenses est alors on
va écouter distincts en manuel bon pari
dit la même chose que vous regardez
il est sur tous les plateaux télé
souvent sans contradicteur zemmour est
candidat sans le dire il fait des
meetings récolte des fonds c'est un
hypocrite
c'était pas le jeûne extrême et un
manuel bompard dit justement comme vous
qu'il qu'on souhaite montrer qu'il n'a
rien à dire sur l'urgence sociale sur
les 10 millions de pauvres dans notre
pays comme sur l'impasse climatique
benjamin cauchy et vous qui avait été
très impliquée dans le mouvement d'aidé
gilet jaune est ce qu eric zemmour n'a
rien à dire sur et social on souhaite
montrer qu'il n'a rien à dire sur lui
je m'explique où on laisse la nouvelle
bombe à s'exprimer
je comprends la patiente je comprends
l'impatience des français à connaître la
déclinaison programmatique des rixes
elle venait à être véritablement
candidats
ce qui est certain c'est qu'aujourd'hui
stratégiquement et biologiquement eric
zemmour cherche surtout à imposer un
thème son thème qui n'est pas celui de
l'immigration comme pourrait facilement
stigmatiser ses adversaires non son
thème majeur c'est le choc des
civilisations alors je comprends les
attentes impatience est ce que monsieur
zemmour devra augmenter ou baisser la
tva est ce qu'il voudra faire en sorte
que la redevance télévisuelle baisse ou
disparaissent que les autoroutes passe
de 130 à 110 km pas mais soyons sérieux
est-ce que les 110 km/heure sur les
autoroutes or ont du sens lorsque l'on
continuera à avoir des attentats
régulièrement sur notre territoire
est-ce que baisser la tva sur les
produits de première nécessité c'est un
ancien j'ai les jeunes pour qui ça aura
véritablement un impact si au coeur de
ce diagnostic et des propositions qui
sont faites pour éviter ce choc de
civilisations entre entre d'un côté les
anglo saxons des nappes renier leur
futur en france et de l'autre côté
l'islam qui cherchent à imprégner et
imposer son idéologie politique en
france est ce que vous croyez forcément
que les citoyens vont vouloir savoir
s'ils vont payer 20 ou 10 9% de pda sur
sur un paquet de pâtes plutôt que de
savoir s'ils vont pouvoir continuer à
vivre sans leurs femmes se voilent est
donc aujourd'hui ils installent le thème
est bien évidemment au cours de la
campagne il installera des thèmes et des
est d aider et des programmes beaucoup
plus précis moi je voudrais juste vous
faire un parallèle avec emmanuel max si
je le demande aux français qu'est ce qui
a fait qu'elle est la mesure phare qui a
fait qu emmanuel macron était lui en
2017 mais certainement pas sa voix
travail c'était certainement pas la loi
retraites puis d'abord n'aboutit pas
mais d'autre part n'étaient pas dans son
programme non il n'y a aucune mesure
phare dans le programmes des manuels
mâcon qui a fait qu'il a été élu c'est
tout simplement parce qu'ils étaient
manuel macron avait ringardisé la classe
politique la vie politique qu'il avait
un souffle et une nouvelle énergie
l'époque le programme est venue après
lorsque vous avez un candidat qui
incarne
les aspirations d'une société d'un
peuple à un moment donné au bon moment
celui d'une élection présidentielle le
programme je ne dis pas qu'il n'est pas
important mais ici les secondaires avons
nous ou pas confiance en eric zemmour
pour lui donner les rênes du pouvoir et
savoir dans quelle manière de quelle
manière le pays sera dans 30 ans ça
c'est pas l'histoire de fait pas
l'histoire des couches
je laisse parler un peu philippe
jamin que chez réponse philippe jure
avec
nous pour ce jeu qui revient bien pour
commencer que eric zemmour a accepté ce
débat également en disant qu'ils
seraient d'accord pour aurait elle un
ogre lequel il raison
le choix qui a été développée là il est
prêt à discuter sur cette partie sociale
il ya quelque chose qui préoccupe tous
les politiques à l'égard de tous les
politiques en dehors du rassemblement
national en ce moment c'est la question
des salaires la question des salaires
c'est quelque chose de spécial moi une
question directe a posé avec paiement
par exemple d'avoir fait mon âme à une
question précise qui est posée c'est
comment financer certaines il ira déjà
en essayant de faire en sorte de deux
d'augmenter les salaires notamment des
femmes de façon qu'elle soit puisque à
puce est égal avec des offres quelle est
sa réponse par rapport à ça voilà les
questions précises qui peuvent être
posées ou
le peut-être candidat aux
présidentielles
eric zemmour devrait pouvoir se
positionner parce que tous déjà entendu
là pour l'instant il l'a déjà dit et
redit je pense que actuellement si on
peut élargir le champ
des des citoyens à écoute de ce débat ce
soir il faut être capable de pouvoir
discuter d'autre chose c'est-à-dire
d'écologie de salaire et de répondre par
des ânes par des propositions précises
tout j'ai entendu la super présent on
l'a entendu chez zemmour mais sur tous
les plateaux ya rien de nouveau rien
peut-être aussi les mesures allaient
grâce justement à ce débat est ce que la
france insoumise et jean luc mélenchon
ne ne profite pas d'ailleurs ce débat
pour redorer un peu ça
sa popularité puisque vous le voyez sur
ce sondage qui va s'afficher la france
insoumise de jean-luc mélenchon et à 11%
tout comme eric zemmour finalement
est-ce que c'est pas l'occasion aussi de
relancer un peu la campagne de jean-luc
mélenchon pour moi avec des monstres
c'est un avis personnel pour moi eric
démontré par des p tits en ce sens que
il est nostalgique de la france d'avant
voilà tout ce qu'il explique c'est une
idée de la france d'avant on pense qu'il
a connues peut-être celle qu'il a connue
quand il a voté mitterrand en 1981 les
voiliers jean luc mélenchon ce soit il
se met à ma place moi philippe duret
vert il est actuellement conseiller
régional anti impérialiste et qui a
beaucoup milité dans milieu social et
tout à l'heure dans le monde pendant une
bonne heure je rejoins des salariés
voyez salariés de transdev
qui vont manifester devant le conseil
régional parce que ce sont des gens
qu'on ait travaillé 45 heures pour être
payées 35 heures laquelle mans pourquoi
parce que dès l'ouverture la concurrence
et le dumping social se fait du fait de
cette affaire la concurrence et voilà ce
qui arrive actuellement en concret il ya
des milliers de gens qui sont prosternés
des salariés mais aussi des usagers face
à ces questions concrètes et jean luc
mélenchon comme vous dites qu'il profite
de cette situation non c'est qu'elle
était d'un combat au quotidien qui mène
donc la nasa appel à moi d'en décrypter
les rapides pad avec les salariés de
candeur ville en pense quoi monsieur le
déborder tous à quelque chose qui
préoccupe pas des cancers en
ile-de-france de savoir que des âneries
matp sncf et du privé trentaine et auris
l'attention des millions de français en
ville de pan cela ne concerne pas
d'accrocher celle concerne
bien évidemment
vous voyez quelqu'un doit être saluée en
disant qu'il va servir le but elle là ça
j'en suis pas convaincu ce que je veux
dire par là c'est que mesure qu'on
attendait mais vous allez abondé dans
votre sens
le président
a commencé de manière extrêmement
délicate et le maton va continuer vers
si les mesures évidemment deux
quotidiens vont être déployés durant la
campagne effectivement le mal être
social dont à titre personnel je suis et
qui ment très sensible les conditions de
travail
énorme énormément de sauce le pouvoir
d'achat l'environnement est ce qu'on va
continuer à faire croire aux français
que ce en mettant des éoliennes et
dénaturer notre nos beaux paysages
français qui font des dizaines de
millions de touristes viennent en france
est ce que c'est la solution beauté car
j'avais un cocher l'égalité des salaires
bien sur l'égalité hommes-femmes dans
les salaires c'est une évidence et je
crois que sur l'ensemble de l'échiquier
politique ce n'est pas ce n'est pas un
problème
ce n'est pas un problème idéologique
pour l'ensemble de la classe politique
est heureusement les mentalité ont
évolué heureusement que les femmes ont
pu accéder à de nombreux métiers moi
j'en suis fort thèse je pense que
l'ensemble des gens qui sont aux côtés
d'eric zemmour pour réfléchir à l'avenir
du pays sont évidemment cela et quand on
parle d'égalité homme femme c'est
certainement pas en permettant des pans
entiers de notre société
des pans entiers de nos territoires de
voir des femmes qui n'ont pas le droit
de rentrer dans un bistrot ne subira
dans certains quartiers abandonnés de la
république ce n'est pas en faisant
marcher les femmes à deux mètres
derrière leurs maris complètement dégagé
derrière une burqa que l'on peut parler
de l'égalité hommes femmes donc si vous
voulez faire un procès d'intention à
eric zemmour en disant qu'ils ne
s'occupent pas de l'égalité hommes
femmes je crois que c'est important je
pense aux salariés de transdev ce matin
effectivement public dans des conditions
de travail extrêmement compliqué de 45
heures je pense effectivement que la
contrainte la contrainte économique pèse
une immigration massive sur notre pays
ne va pas davantage et salariés d'une
autre pays hélas ce n'est pas de la
fabulation fasciste d'extrême droite je
reprends simplement les mots que georges
marchais disait lui-même en 1981 georges
marchais qui a priori était plus proche
avec plus d'appétence idéologique avec
jean luc mélenchon avec d'autres
personnages là un philippe jura verts
voulaient réagir oui bah oui parce que
je vous propose de venir voir et de
rencontrer notamment des termes
d'origine musulmane ils conduisent les
carcans lève là ce matin et vous verrez
que ça a été des 50 est plébiscité que
quand durant toute la période de
pandémie elle était là pourquoi courir
en des risques assure est toujours dit
non ce moment ne payez pas qu'elle
ignore les problèmes qui peuvent exister
dans les quartiers mal de vivre au
quotidien et à se battre comment elle se
bat en travaillant un sauvage en rendant
service aux citoyens restons battant
l'entente d'une mission de service
public et moi je pense que là
actuellement quand elle me dégoûte tout
ce que vous le raconter leur apprenais
rien du tout mais rien du tout le combat
cannelle elle ne mène pas que pour elle
le même temps lorient en leven pour
aujourd'hui dans leur quartier un manque
de faire suivre par louis
complètement abandonné
des quartiers où il ya des douanes
réalisé par des racailles à l'entrée des
quartiers où même les chauffeurs de bus
se font caillasser se font agresser donc
effectivement ce problème du coaching
l'immédiateté économique et social de se
lire mais ces lignes et c'est peut-être
inhumain de les faire travailler 45 eur
et sache pas que vous et moi on peut le
partager y compris l'ensemble des
auditeurs de la défense mais moi je ne
supporte je ne supportais certainement
pas que les chauffeurs de bus de
transferts continuent à se faire
agresser à se faire
on dirait attaqué physiquement
verbalement
suivra évidemment cette question ce soir
je l'imaginais je voudrais vous faire
réagir quand même philippe juraver parce
que la gauche parle de faute politique
d'avoir accepté ce débat écouter ce
qu'on a dit yannick jadot
on appelle ça gratte et le buzz il voit
une bulle médiatique et se dit peut-être
ça va m'inspirer un peu dans ma campagne
se débattit monde c'est une faute
politique
parce que encore une fois jean luc
mélenchon candidat d'un programme
eric addo je les entends d'une guerre
dans son débat contradictoire de voix
qui a du mal à placer son poulain donc
évident chaque fois que jean lui aura
cette opportunité il l'aura ce soir il
va développer notre programme est bien
sûr qu'on pense qu'il ya des deux
citoyens de pente à sony qui sont là
pour pouvoir développer ses idées c'est
ce que je vais faire tout à l'heure on
veut être fidèle et toute la journée
dans le cas du conseil national merci
beaucoup à tous les deux merci beaucoup
d'avoir débattue ce matin
je vais beaucoup
mieux et si jean luc mélenchon les
candidats d'un programme espérons qu
eric zemmour soit le candidat d'un
peuple et de candidats france voilà
c'est dit merci beaucoup la suite ce
soir pour ceux qui le veulent merci en
tout cas avoir participé à ce débat en
direct sur rtl france